rebound by Clark he knocked it over to
rivers Arden with the basketball harden
with a drive all the way to the bucket
for two and one and that that's where
James gonna find his open opportunities
drive by
then when he was standing and submitted
era's tried to pass it inside a TJ got
the steel pardon in the open court
hardened to the bucket
sets up Gerald gray yes
[Music]
getting into Gerald Britney does the
rest
and the Rockets up on top lot harder
than it looks
this is a fadeaway three Arden
James Harden trying to keep that leave
for the Houston Rockets up by 3 looking
for more not go down
good defense by Nunnally straight up and
down harden steps back fires - James
Harden with a 17 point third quarter
there's a streak of 20 straight 30
points to the Roger
[Applause]
the white shirts around them again as he
slices through there gets the Andrea if
he makes this free-throw he will have
averaged 40 points for the last 20 games
the white shirts around them again is
easy slices through there
gets the and-one the female